I don't really speak I'm to if you want
me to say something but I'm they can
just I'll just get you to speak to
yours
okay Welcome to our guest speakers
members of the public staff and
counselors and those viewing virtually
to the community well-being committee
meeting I have two apologies from
councelor Richard mcf and councelor Paul
mcf are there any other apologies
please no more apologies could I have
someone move the apologies thank you
thank you councelor
hovell thank you councelor
Reed all in favor please say I
against carried the minutes of the um
the minutes of the community wellbeing
committee meeting on the 26th of the 9th
were confirmed at a full council meeting
on the 10th of the
10th has anyone any conflicts of
interest they would like to
declare there are none we have five
items on the agenda today and our first
one up is some M hiu sou destination
strategy and I'd just like um
Nick to come forward and Amy to present
that to us thank
you Nick is the destination development
advisor for Great South and Amy Young is
the destination development manager for
Great
South the strategy um provides a
blueprint for South's destination
management assisting visitors to have a
quality experience in mura hiu welcome
Nick and
Amy Koto everyone thank you so much for
having us here today um it's exciting to
finally um get back to you to present
this strategy and um the work we've been
doing in this space um in today's
presentation I just wanted to touch a
little um on the importance of Tourism
and destination management to our region
a look at the background to the strategy
and how it was developed before taking a
bit of a look at the plan itself and
what some of our next steps from here
will
be um so tourism has been of key
importance to Madu South and um
obviously for quite some time and been
consistently recognized as a key
diversification opportunity for our
region originally within the sword
strategy um from 2015 but more recently
within the Beyond 2025 Southern Regional
long-term plan where it was identified
as one of those top two diversification
opportunities alongside aquaculture um
and the sector was also the fourth
highest owner for our region pre-co um
and was experiencing strong growth at
that time uh we know tourism Oro has
really strong alignment with our
communities um it has that ability to
bring Vibrance um investment job
opportunities more events and activities
and we definitely see that happening in
the G Community um and to improve
infrastructure um and in areas of the
region where Community boards have
created their own plans such as the
southern district they also reference
that strong desire to grow tourism and
see continue in their place um and
lastly we know tourism is really
important um for our goals to attract
people to live and work in the region
because they' normally come here as a
visitor first so that's their first
interaction with us generally before
they become a
resident so we need a really strong plan
to manage and um I guess the benefits of
Tourism so since 2019 we had the
southern moku destination strategy to
achieve that um it was the first
Regional plan New Zealand to align with
New Zealand Alo government tourism
strategy so we were quite ahead of our
time um on a national scale um but by
2022 um only 3 years into the plan over
2third of the 68 recommendations were
already complete in progress or under
investigation so that implementation had
happened a lot faster than we
expected throughout that same time
around that threeyear period a lot of
game changers for our tourism sector had
also come on board and the form of some
of these key developments um and
movements in that space right through
from that jet service connecting inago
to Oakland and then acting as a gateway
to the rest of the region for those
visitors right through to the
southernway touring Network launch which
again includes the G community and
trying to connect the Lower South
together um and again the huntbridge
track was another one there round um
being a fifth great walk in our region
so really cementing our place in the
outdoor
environment um so the revised strategy
was created at this time for a variety
of reasons firstly we know we had that
significant achievement of the original
plan um which was supported also by MB
through our government funding um and
that postco time um and tourism
landscape does changed with all of these
new developments coming on board and we
have to acknowledge also the impacts of
Co and what that means for AIC sector to
have a fresh um perspective moving
forward uh we also know growth is
predicted to be back at pre-co levels
much sooner than originally expected and
that might lead to pressure at some of
our key destinations within the region
such as Milford uh we really need to
align our activities with our
communities and what they want from
tourism as well as the perspectives of
maninoa um and need to redefine what
success looks like Beyond those purely
economic me measures that we had looked
at in the past um such as visitor spend
and lastly to align with that Beyond
2025 Southland U Regional long-term
planning
process
uh so the process to revie the strategy
was led by Great South um as we uh look
after the Region's two Regional tourism
organizations visit Southland and visit
feldland uh we also were able to get a
strategic Advisory Group um established
to help guide that process and it was
great to have Anne on that group with us
um representing the voice of Gore uh we
had further stakehold and Industry
workshops which um other members of your
team were able to attend which was
really fantastic to have that input um
and other key meetings with different
stakeholders and partners um and we also
conducted some supporting research such
as the community sentiment in relation
to tourism and we had infometrics
support us with a tourism data snapshot
and also forecast forward so we could
look at what might happen in the sector
particularly in that postco space uh and
we also undertook our own survey around
sustainability and where our operators
at on that
Journey so of that research I just
wanted to touch on a couple of the key
pieces here um the community sentiment
in relation to tourism pieace um was
really important because it showed us
what our communities want from tourism
and it heavily underpinned the
development of the strategy uh some of
the key takeouts from that were that our
residents are far more likely to say
they're benefited from tourism than
other others in New Zealand so it
definitely has that reach into our
communities and 85% of our residents
would like to see some growth in tourism
as long as that is well managed um and
of those 30% want to see significant
growth so they definitely see this as an
area that we can build on Within in
midu um there was a higher level of
approval for domestic tourism which is
understandable in the co environment um
and a lower acceptance for growth in
field and and Western Southland um again
that's very highly touristed areas
within our region so not to be um
unexpected there and the desired tourism
Focus was around improving Community
infrastructure um enabling visitors to
travel more widely um so that more of
our communities benefit and attracting a
higher value visitor and value in terms
of those that are aligned with what we
want to achieve within our
communities infometrics and the work
they did with us looked at um two
different scenarios for the recovery of
Tourism postco because it's very
uncertain and quite difficult to predict
particularly at this time um there were
small world which looks at Travel being
limited to New Zealand and Australia um
and the variety of reasons which that
may occur um or unrestricted
international travel as Big World um
back to a scenario we're more familiar
with these were looked at by the RTO
level because they have quite a
different visitor makeup and Fu Land We
heavily International whereas the rest
of the region is more domestic focused
um so in either scenario the visit South
inaro outside of feldland um is expected
to recover to pre-co Levels by the end
of this year um so that's really upon us
and fuing by 2025 2026 depending on the
scenario there so again really strong um
bounce back for the
sector um so with future velopment of
Tourism it's really important that this
is grounded in a destination management
approach uh where we look at the
economic social cultural and
environmental well-being of our people
and our place to achieve this we really
need a strong plan uh we want and we
know our communities want tourism and
strong growth's coming but it needs to
be very well managed we need to sure our
sector closely connected to what our
communities want um and delivering real
benefits that they perceive we also need
to prioritize sustainability and move to
that regenerative future
um and this will require everyone
working together on this journey um
there are multiple stakeholders in the
tourism sector and we see this as a plan
that everyone can get behind and work
together
on so in summary the plan that we're
sharing with you today is a crucial step
in our reimagining of Tourism we see as
a plan for all southlanders uh and one
that seeks to lay the foundations of a
more sustainable and regenerative as
their
economy it will be he is heavily linked
um to our communities like I said
delivering real benefits for them um
manao and working in strong partnership
there with an understanding of to our
moldi values and with sustainability at
the heart of all we do um and that care
for our place and our
environment uh We've created a revised
vision for the sector through this plan
so you can see this really focuses on
our points of difference and what they
are and then how we want to deliver what
we what we seek to
do so within the strategy there are 63
project s identified to deliver the
vision that we've set um and these are
in five sections environmental
stewardship leadership and capability
development access and infrastructure
experience in product development and
sharing our story which is more that
marketing piece and from these we've
identified 24 priority projects which
you see in the tree diagram here which
is also in the strategy document um and
these are those that just have the I
guess the highest propensity to help us
deliver that
Vision there are also five key en that
we've been recognized that will be of
critical importance to the success of
the plan um so the first of these is
around Workforce attraction development
we know across many sectors this is a
challenge um and it probably always has
been a little bit in the tourism sector
but worsened by the impacts of co uh
advocacy and Regulatory planning
references some of those key issues that
are important to our communities and
businesses um at both a regional and a
national level tourism leadership group
uh is a yet to be established group that
um I guess recognizes that a does take a
variety of stakeholders to manage our
destination well um and that we see this
group um being put in place to help
Drive the strategy implementation
forward uh data and insights because
again it's really important to
understand where we've been and where
we're going to and be able to measure
our progress and lastly quality
accommodation development because we
know we are short across the region
despite some new developments that are
coming on um and in some locations this
is putting pressure on housing for staff
and
residents the plan also has a really
strong focus on dispersal uh moving
visitors around the region to help a
alleviate pressure at some of those key
points but also spread the benefits of
Tourism because we want all of our
communities to benefit from that flow uh
achieving this will require a variety of
actions to be undertaken firstly
promoting obviously to encourage that
wider travel um activation of our
regional story and understanding of who
we are and who our people are through
muku the Southland uh looking at that
effective public transport Network um
connectivity a piece as well as
alongside visitor information and how we
help use that to help move people around
and then the development of experiences
across the region just really so that we
give people reasons to want to go to
different places for what they can
experience once they're
there so there are five obviously five
key areas in the plan um the first is
environmental stewardship um and this is
really recognizing the role we have to
play in supporting the sustainability of
sector and identifying priorities to
bring us to that regenerative future
future there are 10 projects in this
area and the key focuses here are our
partnership with the Department of
Conservation again are a key um land
owner but also tourism operator in our
region achieving our sector
decarbonization goals um alongside all
others who are also working on this um
connecting that spatial planning piece
um that we know a variety of
organizations are looking at and
councils um to really help assess
climate change impacts supporting our
operators to improve sustainability um
we have a program that we've developed
around that um over the last two years
that's been working very well um and
educating our visitors and trying to
find ways we can engage them in
Environmental Protection and utilize
that Resource as
well uh in the area of leadership and
capability development this really
recognizes that we need to have um
really strong collaborative Partnerships
um to lead our sector forward um and
Achieve that long-term and responsible
growth of the
sector there are 11 projects in this
area um the first again actually quite a
few of these are really linked to those
key enablers so the leadership group
establishment has in here um the seor
advocacy the Workforce Development data
collection but also Regional
collaboration um and Community
participation um because we want to hear
that Community voice more often uh
rather than just in this the survey
periods uh access and infrastructure
focuses a lot on how we get people to
the region and how we move them around
once they're here um enable that to
happen easily so they can explore what
we have to
offer um so of the 10 projects in here
some of the key focuses are around in
huning our air connectivity again that
direct jet from Oakland has really been
a game changer for our region but what
else we can advocate for in this space
uh the visitor information provision and
that visitor information Network again
is key here uh the mford opportunities
project progression which seeks to kind
of I guess manage the experience in
Milford um and bring wider Southland
benefits from that public transport
options to help move people around we
know this is a real challenge for us
with their low um population bases but
also um our communities want to see this
as well to help them uh and again
cycling and ev- infrastructure which is
another really important piece as we
move towards sustainability but also the
cycle tourism Market is a really
significant one um and it's definitely
seeing strong
growth uh experience in product
development is a key area in the plan um
we really want experiences that we
develop to represent who we are and
create a really strong connection so
that people engage with our um authentic
selves of you know the I guess the yeah
the perspectives of our people and that
want to come and return so that
connection's really built there um there
are 21 projects here so it's a really
key focus in the plan um and this
identifies that we still have quite a
lack of commissionable products or paid
for experiences in our region um we have
that quality accommodation Gap so
there's there's a bit to do in this
space um the focus areas are around
quality accommodation development um
cultural narrative experiences uh the
further development are the key pillars
so those are the things that people
associate with Southland and want to
come here to experience um such as their
food their cycling our walking and night
sky um the urban Rejuvenation and town
story development so they understand
what what each of our um sub Regional
areas or towns um are all about and that
management of Tourism and some of those
key
destinations and lastly the sharing a
story is really about um ensuring that
we stand out in a competitive
Marketplace U we know through Co lots of
regions are definitely competing for the
same visitors so really understanding
what makes us different is important um
and we want to share that with markets
that align with our
values of the liveing projects here some
of the key focuses are the development
of a regional ambassador program um for
those who interact with the tourism
sector um integration of that South and
story M Haku the Southland um the
implementation of our events strategy
because we know they're such a key
driver of visitation um our content and
campaigns around those pillars and our
touring Network
promotion so overall the strategy is
really about building a sector that is
deeply grounded in our people in place
um creating those share benefits for all
while also help creating that
Unforgettable visitor
experience um and so from here we're
currently working on an implementation
plan to support the strategy so this
will look at prioritization of some of
those key enablers um which projects
require advocacy um because there are a
lot of those that identified that may
not be within our power but we we have
the power to build that voice around um
time frames Project Lead and support
organizations because this is not just a
great South plan it will be a regional
plan there'll be others involved in its
um success measurement of success and
then where resources may be required um
for some of those more significant
projects um we've also touched on some
of the focus areas that we see within
the plan that relate to core District
Council um there'll be many more because
a lot of the um projects are quite
Regional but some of these are the more
specific ones um so we've identify the
significance of the mway precinct um and
what that will do for tourism in this
part of the region and that being
launched um Urban rejuvation or model
wide Gore because we know that's
something that you're looking at um
around Street scaping what the city
looks like into the future uh cycle
Trail development and infrastructure um
and we actually um Nick will be sharing
with the the cycle tourism opportunities
assessment that we've been working on um
in the next few weeks um cultural
narrative and experience Development
Across the region um we know and within
this year we know Haka are working on um
upgraded storytelling at to to tourism
sustainability obviously is really
important for everybody so that's around
spal planning supporting our operators
looking at those public transport
networks and waste management um and
implementation of the South medu event
strategy which I know events is really
really um significant part of the G
visitor um
offer um other key considerations are
around probably the tourism leadership
group that I touched on um we would love
to look at perhaps someone from Gore who
may be able to be within that
represented within that group um
implementation and plan involvement um
obviously we'll connect back with you
when we have that draft ready um and
again all working together to try to
leverage external funding for the region
because we know um funding is a hard one
for us all so where we can use what we
have to bring more in from outside the
region that's a win for us all as
well well that's all I had to share
today but more than happy to answer any
questions or have
discussion thank you so much Amy for
that really comprehensive and um I can
see that there's a lot of work gone into
the strategy so are there any comments
or questions for
Amy Council
HOV
just by way of uh introduction um just a
little bit of stats that come out of the
report Gore has mentioned 29 times Tian
50 Milford 67 inaga 124 and Bluff
68 um so um we where do we sit in terms
of priority in terms of where where is
the focus or what do you see as the
potential that we could develop to be a
focal point for tourism activities in
this part of Southland yeah I think you
have a lot of um really strong strength
um going view I think AGR tourism is
obviously a really core part of Gore
with that rural community as well and we
serve a lot of operators in the region
in that space um we've run some
workshops around that over the last few
years as well trying to help um build
that um I think obviously the event
space we've talked about a little bit is
really ke for Gore and a lot of those
events are really key to um what your
people are about you know the country
music scene hwo fashion um to name but a
few I think obviously the hweno
Moonshine Museum and the development
around a food story um is really strong
as well and that combined with the Arts
I think is a really strong Market um who
will be attracted to gore and that fits
in with our wider Regional um food
tourism strategy and things as well is a
really key development um so I think
there's some of the things that yeah you
really have going for you but there's a
lot of potential development in other
areas as well such as cycling which we
hope to be able to um elaborate on in
the coming weeks yeah okay so a couple
of things you mentioned there like the
fashion aren't referred to in the
document um so um I guess from a an
implementation point of view um what's
the opportunity for being a bit more
specific as we move forward and um
probably the second part of that is that
at page 68 it talks about the tourism
leadership group MH now is that a staff
group or is it a governance group uh
that would be more governance level
group and we'd see that um as having
representatives from some of the key
stakeholders who have projects um within
the plan um but also try to get some
representation from different parts of
the region as well um so I think you
know I see a place for our count our
councils within that group um Department
of Conservation for example um yeah some
of those key players without trying not
to make the group too big so it's still
um a good size to be functional but yes
to to help drive thank you so while my
questions might have been S as a little
bit negative there's a lot of really
good stuff in here that I think um gives
us a few leads that I guess as a council
here um there there's some things that
we should be picking up on and and
working together with great self um so I
look forward to that thank you yeah
thank you we' really yeah this document
is all about partnership and working
together I think so it's great to hear
you acknowledge that thank
you councelor
raid
thank you
thanks yes I was just reading today in
the paper about the cruise ship over
summer tended I think nine trips so
given that where Gore is located what
are you going to do to encourage those
people coming off that ship who are very
high value customers to come to gore for
a day trip to look through our Museum
and art galleries and everything else
that they want to see yes so there are
some um of the from the season coming
over to the HOA Museum we just actually
visited before we came here um so there
are 19 I think um births coming into
Bluff um this season obviously more in
feldland and riota um obviously in fand
they don't disembark though so there's
limited opportunity there so I think
there's definitely a strong opportunity
for G it's within a short distance um
and being 19 um and the fact that some
of those cruise lines are already coming
here is really strong so I think the
cruise ship Market is about trying to
build on that year and year and having
that facility is a really amazing
experience for them so I think that's
definitely going to help I understand
that but what what exactly how how are
those people on that cruise ship going
to find out what are you doing as part
of your strategy to um promote through
those Cruise Lines yeah so we um connect
with cruise New Zealand obviously and
they have agents who will reach out when
they want to look at what products might
be available in the region because it's
a very long lead time um yeah upwards of
2 years it can be for them to book those
things in so it's probably down to I
guess the operator as well becoming
proactive with us and trying to connect
them together yeah sometimes they don't
yeah every Cruise Line's a bit different
of how much they want to kind of inte
and get involved with us but we're
definitely I'm probably a connector in
that space CU one of the difficulties
we've had in days gone by is that Google
Maps have actually bypassed Gore um and
so even self-drive tourists um don't
always come this way because the short
trip to get to Queenstown or Tiana out
is through the back road so yeah I think
you um you know if there was some help
in that area would be very beneficial
for us I think the southern way touring
Network that we've launched earlier this
year is a partnership with Oto and
Southland so that's a more of a um
rather than a point to point like the
southern Senate group it's looking at a
network of Roads within the Lower South
so Gore is within that and it features
on that website um and we have all the
there's eight RTO that contribute to
that route and we have a marketing
person um in place to um promote that
and she's very Weare we've had her come
down to the region once already but
we're hoping to get her back and be able
to get her around to experience more
things as well so I think that will help
as well um with people looking at that
route and just looking at other ways
they may be able to get to places rather
than just like you say one route to
Queenstown and we're out we want to slow
people down in our region and get them
to stay here longer and experience more
of what we have to
offer yeah thank
you any more questions or
comments Council
hobell environment South collects about
$1.1 million in levies for the want of a
better term for the cruise ships that go
to Milford I'm not too sure how they
spend that money or whether it's
available for wider tourism activities
are there any Lees paid on the boats
that come into
I think yeah it's the same would go to
environment Southland in that scenario
um I'm not I know that they work on um
environmental I guess some of the work
that they do in that space from that
Livy but down to the actual detail I
probably would need to check that not
yeah can't 100% answer that
one councilor
Fraser just um looking a bit further out
because years ago Milford Sound was land
quench town catch a bus straight into
Milford straight out maybe stay the
night in qu town and out I mean there
must be figures in relation to how many
of those people were that went into
Milford compared to how many drove
in do we is that data still available or
is that still do we know not to that
detail I don't think we can look at the
numbers um of Travelers that go into
mford sound based on the theory and the
and the cruise experience bookings
because that's really what they tend to
do so we have that data that does get
shared with us through Milford Sound
tourism but um that granular detail is
not so um available so yeah
unfortunately but that whole network
around those Whistle Stop trips through
Queenstown is definitely what we have
consistantly over um a long period of
time and will continue to do um is try
and change that direction of travel um
and get people to use you know obviously
inago was a Gateway as well to
experience Mora but also to slow down
and spend time in town now and and
reduce that Whistle Stop visit which is
not a great visitor experience anyway
kind of you know that rushed long car
Journey um in and then out and everyone
tending to arrive around that same time
of day as well which is partly the
reason for some of the congestion that
occurs at
Milford there do you collect data on the
occupation of um motels and
hotels uh there's a national data set
called the accommodation data program so
they collect data around um accommod
that commercial space um so that we look
at all the different different
accommodation types in that sector but
it is voluntary so um with every data
set it's got its I guess um limitations
so but that that is out there readily
available on the MB website and the
reason for asking is that if we're
wanting to encourage more accommodation
there's a threshold above which it's
economic to build more um I'm just
wondering if there's the opportunity of
of accessing some of that and using that
um because in recent months I think
accommodation here in Gore um has been
quite well used and it would be nice to
put that out there and um to a few
investors saying you know it's
worthwhile investing for sure and we're
also um as part of against the Beyond
2025 project as well looking at housing
and and accommodation conducting a bit
of an audit for it in the region what
capacity is at the moment because
obviously with Co there's been some
changes um in the last few years so um
that's quite a manual process takes a
bit of time but trying to understand
where all all our properties are at in
terms of what they have on
offer any more questions Council
Phillips uh thank you mam chair it's not
not not so much a question but just uh a
uh I thank you for the presentation and
their biggest problem is that Queen
sound's on the wrong side of us if Queen
s was into needen would be really great
because then when you're traveling
everyone gets a view of before they go
home again G so but currently when
they're traveling all the views coming
this way are behind them and it's a bit
of a problem so if Queen was on the
other side would be really good right
I'm not sure I can help you with that
one but no it's a big issue it's a big
it's a big um project that one yeah but
I think lots of you know like the hako
Moonshine and things that you're doing
that make this place attractive will
help um encourage people to take a
different route I think just building on
that is really
important any further comments or
questions just one thing that I've noted
um Amy is that I see it's in your key
actions is that you're working with um
businesses that require workers to
provide accommodation and I think that's
that's a huge thing because I know
there's a lot of young people out there
that are sleeping in tents and cars that
are working in some of these places so
definitely agree with you there yeah
there that's a bigger housing picture
for our region as well isn't there that
that links back to for sure yeah so
thank you so much for your presentation
um and um let you get on with your day
okay thank you so much thank
you could I have one somebody move that
the report be received thank you
councelor Philip seconder counselor
raser all those in favor please say say
I against
carried and next presentation is um from
Charlene Taylor girls on the
neighborhood
support thank you
Charlene I see Kelly is here here as
well hello
Kell can you just turn
your hello everybody um I'm Charlene
I've got Kelly with me today I'm new in
the position with neighborhood support
and Kelly's been in the was running the
position before me so she may be able to
answer any questions or jump in um I see
I'm having a few technical already it
seems to be my week for these things the
font has changed on the computer so yeah
we checked it before and it hadn't so
yeah so hopefully it isn't impacting too
much on um what you can read
so so a neighborhood support um you most
of you would have heard of neighborhood
support it's a community initiative and
it's Community Le so how the community
wants to run the program is different in
every area um connects neighbors um with
each other so the neighborhoods are
safer and more caring places to live um
so the aim definitely is to reduce crime
be prepared for emergencies and connect
and um get communities connected and
enhance well-being in the
community um New Zealand neighborhood
support is a registered charity and has
been since
1999 and we work alongside the police
and partners we work really closely with
them and that is to equip the
neighborhoods to improve their safety
and connectedness um and of course be
prepared for emergencies um was made up
of a network of community organizations
um that currently Support over 200,000
out so I think it's around about 220
households and Counting as we
speak
uh neighborhood support initially
started as neighborhood watch and you
may all remember that um and in the
1990s they relaunched it and they
relaunched it to reach out look out and
help out so they took away the um old
way of thinking that we're its
neighborhood watch and watching your
neighbors and why join um when you join
you have a great way to know your
neighbors but you Al receive emails and
alerts um that means it could be a
localized crime report for your area we
don't send out a crime report for the
whole of the area we send it to the
people in their localized area so they
know what's going on in the area Alone
um and that's not to create so we don't
create stigmas in certain areas in the
community Etc and it's really things
that are relevant to what's going on in
your community um and we also provide
tips for safety and preparedness for
emergencies and we of course we have the
access to the neighborhood watch
stickers and the street signs Etc and
lots of information yeah plenty of
information and this is our resources
online and this is everything um that we
can sort of send people for information
and we can get information for them and
as you can see it's not just what the
old traditional neighborhood watch was
we go into all sorts of um further
information for people so lots of
resources
online so getting involved a
neighborhood watch can be whatever you
want it to be and you can join as an
individual or you can join as a
household um in a group a group could be
a church group it could be a business
group all sorts of things so it's is as
much um involvement as you want it to be
and um it can you can join and have
Street barbecues and get to know your
neighbors in a whole neighborhood you
can do Street cleanups Plant swaps um um
anything that the community wants and or
you may just be a household that you
really just want to be individual and
just have the access to information and
the resources and of course it's free
and you can join an existing group or
you can even start your own
one and getting involved um of course
we're always looking for
volunteers that would be the ideal world
so if you know of anybody that's looking
for volun to be a volunteer it's an
ideal opportunity to get them to meet
their neighbors and get involved with
the community um you can get involved by
starting a group um helping at events um
mail drop just get the name out there
and to get people knowing that it is
available in this region um and also
sharing ideas and initiatives which
would be where the plant swaps and
things all came about with people um in
the community getting involved and
actually giving their ideas of what what
they would like to
see and the whole picture
um the whole picture lots of people in
the community are doing a an informal
sort of neighborhood support action I
talked to lots of people and they say
we're already doing that and they're
swapping their information supporting
their neighbors Etc um those simple
changes and things can make such a world
of difference to people's lives um the
with neighborhood support we can make it
formalized which means it might be able
to put a sign up in the street to sort
of help detour crime Etc and also give
them the resources and help them prepare
an event if they want to do a street
event things and of course neighborhood
sport is all about like looking after
your neighbors you know collecting mail
if they're away taking their BN out all
those sort of things which is um what
Community Support really is all
about and how to join um we're based at
Connected Eastern Southland and we have
a national website which can link you to
a join nail form and we have a QR code
that we put on um up in public spaces so
people can actually join very easily and
um that joins the
database uh recently cie and I were
luckily we were very lucky to go to the
um National Conference up in Wellington
and that was my very first day of work
with neighborhood port and it was a
perfect opportunity because I actually
got to Dive Right on meet people that
have been doing it for a long time
around the the communities in New
Zealand and um got lots of ideas and
made lots of connections and just and I
saw how successful it could be and how
important and the changes that people
are making to their communities it was
really fantastic opportunity to go to
that yeah it was really
good um connected communities are
happier and healthier there's a lot of
research um about around loneliness and
what people want
connectedness and so on in society um
there's a lot of actual research on the
financial cost to a community when there
is loneliness and people aren't
connected um and this of course put
demands on social care and the
environment and one of the big research
um pieces that were done this was solely
done on the um cost of to the community
on not being connected and loneliness so
um it was a big study and it showed that
there was a big Financial cost to the
community and of course to local
governments etc for um when communities
aren't
connected and so there is yeah a benefit
by increasing social connection um and
of course um feeling lonely and feeling
isolated um leads to people using using
um alcohol and getting depression and
and that leads to other health
conditions um and of course we all know
that with Co there's been like a
disconnection with society and there's a
lot of people who are isolated so um
they're vulnerable to all these um fur
the things that affect
them so um connected communities can
work together to find Solutions to the
local issues and this is where um the
the benefit of um connected communities
can come through like some areas of
adopted cleanup days it could be a local
stream or a park um book swaps plant
swaps seed swaps um talking to each
other and quite often the community has
solutions to some of the things that are
going on in their neighborhood um so
people together can be quite strong and
finding
Solutions
and um knowing what who your neighbors
are what skills and resources they can
provide in time of need um obviously
quite often the first person to respond
in an emergency is a neighbor and um
neighborhood sport has a database that
people can join and they put their
resources and skills on there so in a
street I can see immediately fter down
to anyone that's got medical um training
or they may have um a generator or um
the ability to cook with power Etc so um
that's all about knowing your neighbors
and their skills and the resources and
that's something that NE neighborhood
support um encourages with our
database and basically NE yeah neighbors
are the First Responders in time of
emergency quite often um and that's
talking about our database and having
access to our database in a civil
defense Emer agency um super quick to
fter down and find who's vulnerable in
needs help and this is our database it's
called gets ready it's very user
friendly and we sign people up they can
go on the datab base themselves and they
can actually update the information is
needed um this is where where it comes
into play is when there is an emergency
um so anyone vulnerable um for all sorts
of variety of reasons in the community
um in the event of like a flooding or so
on we can um Lea with councel and we can
actually know who to go out and see
straight away and ideally in in an Ideal
World with um neighborhood support
there'd be one person in the street that
we could contact and then they could go
out in the street and um check on the
vulnerable people um and but because
we've got access to that information
quite easily um and of course the um
skills and needs and resources is on
there as well and it's a Ure
database and that's just saying and I
use the database also to that's I send
the crime reports out localized crime
reports um but I can also send out any
eludes to areas so that could be any
Council matters of so on as well could
be roading flooding all sorts of things
or um any upcoming projects and um
emergency preparedness and so on
so how can um nabood support help local
help local government so we definitely
have a common goal um connecting the
community and making it safe and
resilient um and some of the support
that would we'd like to continue with
the gore District Council giving us
support and putting our signs up for
neighborhood support um and we're very
appreciative because we've had lots of
support um with the sharing
communication being involved with events
and um so on and and sharing my events
on the um chinwag for example so yeah
that's great
collaboration um that I'm getting with
the G District
Council and the benefits of
collaboration um as a neighborhood sport
coordinator I'm here I do will and do
get to hear people's concerns in the
community and that could be that's crime
concerns it could be lighting it could
be um things to do with um their
Community feeling secure um and some of
that is School District Council related
and I could feed that back and it just
makes a um nice userfriendly way for
people to feed that information back and
um relevant information can come back
easily and that would be a good um way
to Lea with the council um the database
that we can activate an emergency that's
um very important and working with the
gore District Council as we know with
the recent floods possibility of the
floods getting worse um so your support
with council is definitely
invaluable and the other thing with
neighborhood support is that the
information that the people get is
verified because um the in the um
Community groups from for example on
Facebook there seems to be lots of
information that floats around but not
all of it is correct um so the good
thing is with neighborhood forward I can
actually send out verified information
and that through my database so that's
another way if there is anything you'd
like to feedback I can feed it back to
my database too as well and not everyone
is on social media so the database is
helpful to send them out an email and
with people there A lot of people in the
community don't have um email email so
what I do is try to find someone in
their street that does so that any of my
emails can actually be fed back to the
people and that's neighborhood sport as
well um neighbors supporting each other
and and the face tof face connection
they've got me and Cali supporting so
they do have that um face t- face
connection with neighborhood support in
this
area and looking forward um definitely a
more connected community and having
community events and um meeting PE
getting people together I'd love to see
Community startup um active events like
cleaning up an area or cleaning up a
street all sorts of things in that um
area um youth engagement I think this
would be wonderful if we could get our
youth more in evolved with the community
and um those people will be following
that through for the rest of their life
in this area um the business groups I
think that would be a good support for
them um especially with the crime in
security and we Lea with the police so
there's um there could be things that
people have concerns with I can take
back to the police and having drop in
sessions to make the community
comfortable just to come in and that's
been fantastic because the library have
let me have sessions there and that's
been a very good support and we've just
done um a collaboration with ready for
living we did a scam awareness Workshop
yesterday and that was a great success
over 50 people attended
and I think the feedback was fantastic
really good event I got a message from
one of the attendees today this morning
saying I was just about to open the list
that my parcel from teu had been
misdelivered but after yesterday I
thought I put it in the Del box so that
work yeah the one person but that was
actual yeah proper feedback from the
events that was worth
doing so and together as
um elected members you have obviously
very community-minded and I hope you can
see the um value of the um neighborhood
support in your
community now this um unfortunately the
font has changed and um made it hard to
read um So Christine dorsy in white she
had sent this through um on a newslet
and I just thought it was fantastic um
this was her what does it mean to belong
to Neighborhood support and she said
this is something I've personally
pondered over I've come up with the
thought that if you're involved with
neighborhood support in any way shape or
form you are appreciating and
acknowledging value of supportive
neighbors by doing this you're also
making a silent pledge that if there's
any kind of disaster or issue you will
look out for each other in your
neighborhood as needed so I thought that
was a really nice way of putting it as a
silent pledge that you go out to support
your neighbors
oh thank you any
questions thank you Charley thank you
that was a really good report um any
questions comments councelor hoval and
councelor Reed do you have um many
neighborhood support groups in rural
areas not a good question not as yet and
that is something I definitely am trying
to reach out to the rural community
we're going to field days and that we
hopefully we'll be able to reach quite a
few people there um but that is
definitely um on the radar and something
that would hope gets up and running yeah
and much needed too because of the crime
statistics in the area is actually a lot
of rural crime activity criminal
activity we don't have groups formal
groups as such in the rural space but we
do have a lot of household in thatal
space we did
community in windh and there was members
from the surrounding are coming into
those as well and most of them signed up
so they taking it back out into just not
aized
group councelor
Reid thank you madam chair um thanks
lady great presentation um I'm very
happy to say that I am a member of
neighborhood supportful and I really
appreciate the um quite Fallen accurate
um emails that we do get when there's a
little bit of flooding or even power
lines you know poers off things like
that um we also of course get that
information via an tenno but it's
actually really good to have oh did I
read that properly let's do it again um
the one thing I will say two questions
and I know the first one's probably
going to be yes but do you include your
brochures in the welcome and Community
packs ands nodding I know that's is just
checking um and as far as the youth go
um like today at high school I know the
Junior school um spent the day out in
the community and that would have been
an ideal opportunity for them to be able
to come to you ladies and have a
presentation and perhaps deliver some
pamphlets for you um so you know going
forward I'm sure that if you able to
approach somebody like it would be a
really good move that's fantastic yeah
fantastic idea thank you charene has as
you said been in the RO for a very short
time today uh it started very
intense inton um but it's been amazing
and the work I'm going to talk about
she's not standing beside me the work
that she's done today already has been
phenomenal um so many things that we had
wanted to do since we first launched the
project did not have the capacity to do
so so yeah I just hats off to Charlene
for everything that she's done so far
today and the immense ideas that she's
got going forward as well I can't wait
to see them roll
out but that is a fantastic suggestion
here so we just weren't ahead enough of
the schedule to be looking to support
that the go students but yeah that's
fantastic neighborhood support New
Zealand as a national operation has a
whole youth strategy as well so they're
really Keen to promote that um it's kind
of dissipated a little bit over the
years they really came to reinvigorate
that so I think that's a really good
opportunity we can
be thank you councilor Fraser thanks mam
chair um firstly just on the rural one
would not an approach to Federated
Farmers be a good idea because they
probably have the ear of 90% of the
people um yeah that's just that's what I
thought they but I'm I'm personal not
I'm more of a comment than anything as
an ex policeman um as a community
constable in in Vago the neighborhood
support was invaluable and then as a
rural policeman the the information you
get back from a well supported well
setup neighborhood group is amazing
whether it
be the neighbor Jim I haven't seen him
for two days and I know personally how
that has affected some families and what
we've found but it is and it's
supportive but I think Council readers
right the youth is going to be your
problem because you've got to beat this
and how do you beat that and it's
getting them supported in the community
and unfortunately we have parents now
who are the same as that they have no
idea who their neighbor is so good luck
you'll have my support thank
you there's been some really cool things
done to engage young people up and down
the country from sites um yeah some
really Innovative stuff one of our
colleagues coordinator colleagues
she number eight wi L this incredible
basketball setup to the roof of her car
um using some gathered up bits and
pieces and she takes that out into the
streets and they've actually created
neighborhood support as a street for
young people so it's a mobile Street the
car is the street it is the group she
drives the car around to where young
people meet and that's the touch point
they come in and start throwing
basketball to the through the on her car
while she talks to them ands to while
they're around and she done some stuff
with that and it was just all kiwi
number donated goods and she found some
stuff
that incredible like it's there it's
finding what that is
yeah any further questions
comments thank you Charlene Kelly I do
remember neighborhood watch a number of
years
ago neigh
neighb I
think yeah I think you need a new
one thank you for your time and As shene
Leaves the um um room uh our next item
deals with the meral task force for jobs
and thank you for the input that you've
had on that um which is acknowledged in
the report um was appreciated thank you
thank you thank you Charlene and Kelly
and Charlene I know that you'll go from
strength to strength and do a wonderful
job thank you thank
you could I have somebody um move the
report be received thank you councelor
Reed councelor hoval seconded or in
favor against
carried move on to item three the gore
District Council work force survey
analysis um a community strategy manager
an do you have anything further to add
to your tabled report
an
thank
you okay let's do this thank you um
cheer some of you all remember that we
did a scoping exercise with business and
we've done it twice and this is the
third time and the the reason I guess
we're doing this is to have a really
good understanding of what's happening
and the business Community from an
employment point of view but also some
of the challenges and if you look back
to the previous year when our businesses
were talking about Labor shortages um
probably 80 plus% we're saying they had
labor shortages there's still quite a
substantial amount of businesses in
Industry at 41% of those that we
interviewed so we've interviewed um 80
businesses and this was done independent
from
Council so maybe I just see if you've
got any comments or questions because
it's pretty self-explanatory with the
with the um graphs
ET comments or question questions please
councelor Fraser and then councelor
hovel um thanks and I just looked at um
the businesses that were interviewed
were they was that a were they asked
they want to
compare told or not because I just look
at the industry I'm in there's of I know
eight eight in the in in the gore town
that actually contribute to the
community probably over 140 odd workers
and we're not actually I can't see us in
here and it might be us going no we
don't want to do it but I just I just
wonder how they selected the businesses
to be interviewed um It's a combination
like we have quite a substantial
database of businesses um some had been
inter interviewed previously there was
some clear gaps and so we made sure that
we tried to plug those gaps and get a
balanced perspective Ive across the
various sectors and the segmentation is
based on the government segmentation so
if that we want to match up the data um
to the National Data we can so um yes
some businesses said no we don't want to
do it some had done it in the past and
didn't want to do it this time so it's a
bit of a mix
um okay so the the agriculture um there
definitely is agure businesses there and
they're sitting under the agriculture
fishery and and Forestry and that's the
government classification and we didn't
want to mix mess up those
classifications so those businesses are
sitting in that category yeah
yeah councelor
H an amazing piece of work in terms of
the data that's been pulled together and
and for all those involved um superb
what are you going to do with it um so
the process already what we've done is
um we have actually the raw data and
we've pulled some components out of that
so with the mural task force for jobs
program for example the uh some of the
questions were around whether people
wanted to participate like in Gateway or
some of the other programs for young
people so those businesses that have
said they want to um we can have a
conversation with them and link them up
to those programs we've analyzed the
information around where businesses have
said but they need more help with HR
accounting all of those types of things
so some of that information we're now
working with great South because they
deliver those training programs into
Gore and so instead of it just being you
know a random idea let's deliver this
we're asking them to deliver what
businesses have said so and we're
pulling on the data based on a range of
different projects we're working on yeah
and some of it's about the
implementation of the workforce plan and
some of it's about um delivering on a
task
force because it seems that one of the
major issues is still a shortage of
schooled labor that's great um so um I
guess the the what what is it that we as
a council can do to help that okay so
there's a project starting early in the
new year which is about attraction and
retention and this project is led by
Great South for the wi Southland but our
G businesses said they want a gentric
approach so Our intention is we've
already hold the list of businesses that
are over a certain number of staff and
um we going to come together and discuss
some of their challenges around
attraction and retention and what they
would like to see so that's kicking off
in the new year we've already had those
businesses in the room earlier this year
trying to address uh more what I'd say
as minor issues but some of those issues
related to our welcoming community space
which were around
um work visas
um immigration trying to get residency
where businesses here have very good
staff but they want to keep them and
they want to have them um become
citizens of New Zealand really so some
of those things some of our um big
employers have told us around challenges
of getting bank accounts working with
the IID so there's lots of things that
are happening on a daily basis that are
individual to either individuals in
their Community or or the
businesses
councelor Reed um thank you madam chair
just to that last point a I was just
talking to somebody the other day who
was saying that um one of the
challenges for people when they're
employing um people from overseas and
they need to have all their information
there so they can open bank accounts for
them for their wages to be paid into Etc
and because of language challenges
sometimes the employer will help them
with that but it's actually the hours
that the banks are keeping um making
huge profits cutting services but um
apparently people still have to run
after them so that's a challenge for a
lot in our community and um yeah just
thought I'd mentioned that one of the
biggest challenges we hear about is when
people come to live in Gore and they're
working for larger companies and they
don't have a permanent street address
and if you don't have a permanent street
address you can't open a bank account
and so often it's either good
relationships through our staff or from
the camp staff that help bridge the gap
to get those things in place so there's
all sorts of little things that make
life quite tricky and difficult for
people and hence the welcoming Community
project um because that you know helps
us Bridge some of those things so quite
a bit of the work the team is doing like
this is one piece but it's Crossing into
the other spaces of the work we're doing
yeah it's it's an amazing amount of work
that you and the team are doing it's
just
so beneficial for the community um that
wasn't actually my main question um it
was just a comment but um I just
wondering how when you've been um
talking with retailers and looking at
the survey results are you finding them
retailing more or less optimistic than
they have been in previous surveys I'm
less
optimistic and how are they Co what are
their intentions
of I don't know
you know online trading is such a big
um black cloud really for our small
rural communities where we want to keep
retailers open and have our Main Street
looking vibrant and busy um is there any
intention from the retailers as a group
to have strategies to deal with that to
promote the town Etc um definitely as a
small group of proactive retails ters
that are working together um some of you
might be aware of your Facebook page and
I know I know they're working on some
projects for this Christmas period at
the moment and I know they get together
and they also have have had social
events where they've had speakers yeah
and so my team J Lea um with that group
yeah yes got I know there's some younger
people amongst that and they're quite um
enthusiastic and able to put the time in
thank
you councelor
McKenzie
mayor
please thank you I would just like to
concur with Council Reed about the bank
opening airs it's a bloody disgrace in
this town excuse my language but it is
um for people that have come into town
Etc that's just a comment but the other
thing I want to mention an is something
that we seem to come back to a lot is
accommodation and housing for workers
getting them to stay here finding
somewhere for them to live that'll be on
your agenda I would say is that a big
problem it is a big problem and we just
hosted the welcoming communities lunch
today and after that I was talking to
quite a few businesses and some of them
are big employers and they were still
citing that um finding rental properties
um Froning permanent housing some of I
know have even had like Camp hire camper
fans um to get you know to bridge that
Gap until they can find something so yes
it's still a major problem for us I
don't know what the solution is but it
is something that we've got to look at
really thank
you
wish uh just on that housing one uh and
I think H will be aware of this um but
great s so Bobby's um indicated the next
steps for the uh Regional housing
project um which was start to address a
lot of those those issues so I can send
out that email um so that all elected
members have it did you have a copy of
that as well an um I just received an
email in the last 24 hours from Bobby
yeah yeah it'll be that one yeah okay so
I'll send it out to eled members so they
can have a read through it's quite
thorough um on what the next steps
are comments councelor read um just a
comment actually in on the fact that
your team are organizing the new
citizenship ceremonies um I've only
managed to make one but it was really
well done and um really important for
all of those people to um have a little
bit of fuss made of them and as you've
been doing um for it's a it's a long
process and it's exceptionally expensive
and for some people it's a huge um part
of their lives and I think it's really
good to see it acknowledged properly and
with ceremony and dignity thank you
thank
you no further
comments and I have couple of questions
I was just going to ask you the 90-day
trial do you think that that could
assist employee ear I think is from what
I've heard from some of our businesses
are happy with the 90day trial okay
that's great um and the other thing was
that I noted that 60% of the businesses
are unware of the business support group
is that on their website I mean it's
quite a few isn't
it uh that was the business that's the G
business Network that Karen
runs okay yeah so that is actually we do
we do publicize that and we have
publicized it on our Facebook page and
we've recently started a newsletter so
whenever they're doing anything or if
they wanted to share information we
would certainly put it out um and you
know we we would want to see that grow
yes great and I also wondered if coun
can do something about bcal like we did
um say that so my understanding is um
the go retail uh was is really that
group is managing all of that and
council's involved in that process
anymore we're looking at a bigger the
bigger picture I guess um that used to S
under Sonia yeah is a marketing
initiative that's right yes yes no well
thank you an that was a great report and
as everyone has said um it it's really
great for Council to have all that data
in front of us to help make decisions so
thank you for all the work that you've
done
there
um would someone like to move that the
report be received thank you councelor
Fraser second and councelor Reed or in
favor please say I against carried item
four once again is a community strategy
manager aan um and the report is tabled
and do does anyone have any questions or
comments do you have anything further to
add first um I probably just want to
comment on mural task force and we've
got our lovely M here who might want to
comment as well because he's the tiger
head for this project and is sitting on
the inner group in Wellington for M task
force but um we've entered this
financial year it took quite a while to
get a contract from Wellington and the
outcomes we need to deliver is 25
outcomes and um we've been very lucky
when we had Charlene and she did an
awesome job and she's I really do want
to acknowledge her because she's helped
transition across or out of the role and
help Joe and Joe's with us because many
of you haven't met Joe um how many weeks
Joe five weeks and we are sitting at 13
outcomes at the moment with potential of
being maybe around 19 at the start of
February um so we have to get 25 by the
end of July but that's um outcomes that
are MSD outcomes there are other
outcomes over and above that which are
people that are not neat so not
unemployment training or education
and I also want to welcome gam who is n
weeks in the job who's sitting in the um
welcoming
communities um space and also going to
be the person implementing the workforce
plan so a lot of her work crosses into
that meral task force as well from the
business side of it so I feel like M
husp for us is in really good hands
we're making good progress um be do you
want to call me before I move on to some
of the other topics in the
report yeah sure thanks an um as
councilors probably don't know actually
um as an mentioned I sit on the group of
core members for
mfj um which is currently going under
not so much a restructure but a bit of a
strategy session of what is our mission
and vision and where do we take it from
here um as some of you may or may not be
aware uh the program got refunded this
year for uh 12 $12 million I think it
was overall um but that funding so it
got funded for two years 12 million this
year and 10 million next year so there's
a $2 million shortfall for the next year
um that's going to be really difficult
to fund across across the country um
that's only that's why we only have 25
outcomes um compared to 50 the year
before of the program just can't afford
it um and unfortunately it's little
counil like us that suffer the most um
and ultimately it's the the kids who who
suffer so we're looking for alternate
funding whether that's through uhe or um
other partners other government
departments who can who can um add some
funding to the mech so um that's quite a
large piece of work but hopefully we can
get that over the line so we can get um
that that topped up while I have the mic
as well just want to say huge um
congratulations and well done to an um
to bring on the two staff members that
she has um it was a pretty di straights
here for a moment of um and was looking
like she was going to be flying solo Oh
with Kylie sorry as well um but yeah
somehow managed to pull out of the bag
and it's done an incredible job with um
two awesome new hirs so um what will be
said to to those Charlene and Mark um
you've you've done an excellent job to
find replacement so very well done thank
you
um um I think we haven't really lost
charene because um the neighborhood
support we've already done a joint
initiative yesterday and when the floods
happened um neighborhood support were
really fantastic with delivering to our
community and and giving us access to
information and getting messages out so
probably the only other thing I'd like
to comment on is the welcoming
communities um we just haven't had any
staff to actually deliver this program
this year but in the short time G's been
with us we've done a huge amount of work
and we've basically connected with all
the players that are in this space at a
national level and we still have a few
at a regional level to connect with but
today we actually relaunched the welcome
pack we had the partners that have been
delivering the welcome packs and they
were all incredibly positive we had them
in for a lunch and explained to them the
process and um gave them a new welcome
pack we've also launched a newsletter to
a welcoming community's participants so
anybody that's new or is a partner and
that's been really well received so
really looking forward to getting into
next year and really getting this
cranking along um so it's in a good good
space so I'm pretty happy about that
yeah thank you an questions or
comments your worship thank you madam
chair um probably could have this
conversation offline and but just
wondering if there's any update on the
uh Health locality um primarily around
boundaries I know um we've kicked it
around as a bit of a political football
every time it comes up to a governance
level um but it seems to then go away
and we don't hear about it yeah I have
to say sitting on the governance
actually we haven't heard about it
either for a while so it's something I
can bring up at a next meeting and see
where it's at and and report back to
you any further questions
comments thank you Ann I know that
you've done a huge amount of work and to
get this strategy cross the line so
thank you to you and and your co-workers
thank you done a fantastic
job um I'd like someone to move the
report be received please thank you
worship
seconder Council
Phillips all in favor please say I
against
carried so our last item is item five
it's a minutes of the grant subcommittee
meetings um I'll just pass over to your
worship
to follow up on that
please thank you madam chair um and
grants committee members feel free to
jump in at any point um just after a
conversation we had um as you'll see
there's two sets of minutes in there um
one with recommendations of a Way
Forward uh and the second meeting of
just receiving the presentations um the
conversation was around we didn't
particularly want to send the minutes
the some off with approvals and some not
so um after discussions with the chair
of the grants committee um whether there
was a recommendation falling out around
um pulling those recommendations back um
so that the grants committee can have a
full conversation about all the grants
together uh and then pushing those onto
the the ltp committee was that
correctable so it can be um discussed
there um so would you like me to
formulate a recommendation for that
there any questions on that process it's
a bit messy but um might be the best way
to tackle them all together I appreciate
that thank you your
worship you have a question yeah thank
you madam chair um sorry what committee
was that going forward
to so the grants committee send it
through to this Committee in the in the
minutes and then it would usually go
through the council but it's only got
half of them with actual approved grants
and the other half don't yeah so be
going back to the grants committee so
they can pull them all together and then
send it through the
ltp does that make sense it's a bit
messy I know
Co but we will um we can move that the
minutes of the grant subcommittee
meetings held on the 25th of October and
the 8th of November be received
would you like to add to that
recommendation your worship councelor
hobell are you quandering
something all right thank you so could I
have somebody move please let the
minutes be
received thank you councelor Phillip
seconder thank you councelor all in
favor please say I sorry uh Madam chair
um I don't you were at were you there
for the whole meeting of the second
one well saying he receiv they just
received okay myy them I just re sorry
sorry my B okay so we move on a second
all in favor please say I against
carried Council
hovell useful
to thank you um it' be useful input to
the grants committee to actually be
aware of other funding that may be
available to community groups um
particularly when it comes to looking at
a budget for moving forward and whether
something should go to other
organizations rather than through
Council don't know if Council Phillips
wants to head to the
edit Council PHS yeah thanks mam chair
the this part of the reasoning is that
um the key groupings of the grants
funding uh hasn't been really discussed
yet and this is probably a bit of a pro
we're probably be doing the grants a
little bit ahead of time and so we've
got to really figure out uh what
sponsorship funding is what the mou
Agreements are the projects and the
contracts for services that we have and
also the council subcommitte
so we have to uh organize all those sort
of into into groups first before we can
actually um issue that the
sponsorship or grants whatever they may
be hence
the the um probably the recommendation
that that worship is going to put
forward to to bring towards Council for
for a decision later on thank you
Council
Phillips any more comments before before
we put a
recommendation I can read out the
recommendation happy for it to be
Wordsmith as well so um that the
community well-being committee requested
the garance committee reconsider um the
below recommendations as part of wider
ltp
conversations is everyone happy with
you'd like to move that happy to move
that and could I have a second for that
recommendation
please C
McKenzie all in favor please say
I
against
carried Council Phillips thank you m I'd
just like to um for people that may be
um watching this online or or whatever
all the um reports that may come out is
that we're going to be doing this as
swiftly as possible um and we are aware
of um some of the financial uh
implementations that May uh bring upon
some of the people that are forwarding
their grants to us so you know we're
doing this as fast as we
can I think it is important that people
do know that thank you so that bring
they will not be
forgotten please pleased to hear that so
that brings us to the end of our meeting
today thank you for attending and as
this is the last meeting of the
community wellbeing committee for 2023
I'd just like to wish you all a safe
relaxed and happy Christmas break thank
you